So, I'm Jim Rehg. I'm a professor of
Computer Science at the School of Interactive Computing at Georgia Tech.
And I work in computer vision and machine learning,
and I've got an interest in human behavior.
Sure.
So, the goal of behavioral imaging is to be able to measure,
analyze and understand human behavior using sensors and machine learning.
And the idea is to go from current qualitative understanding of behavior based on
human observation and ratings to really be able to objectively
measure behaviors as they're being produced in the real world environment.
And this involves a lot of sensors and a lot
of analytic methods to analyze the data produced by
the sensors and ultimately build models of behavior.
Sure.
So, for example,
one of the things that we can do recently that's become feasible and
realistic is to allow people to wear
cameras as part of going about their daily activities.
And we see this in a variety of settings with sports enthusiast.
And we're beginning to see this more and more in other settings,
social settings and so forth.
And so we have an effort where we're using individuals that are caring for children with
developmental conditions and those individuals
can wear a pair of glasses that contain a camera,
and that wearable camera allows us to see in the video what the child is doing as far as
how they're expressing themselves socially and
any lack of social interaction or social expression.
And we've got some technology for quantifying
a particular element of their social interaction which is looks to the eyes.
So eye contact is a critical part of social interaction.
And with this technology, we can actually measure quantitatively how
frequently and for how long will children look to the eyes of their caregiver,
and that becomes a quantitative marker or
measure for a child's social behaviors as they evolve
over time through development.
Right. So definitely, there's a lot of interest around understanding how to get
behavioral measures which really speak to
an individual's daily life experiences into the care process.
If you think about mental health and in general,
there's a lot of difficulty in getting beyond the self-report,
where you ask a patient,
what have you been experiencing? What are your issues?
And so, we do think that these new sensor-derived measures could
become a way to allow a care provider to get a richer,
more fine-grained picture of how
a patient's state of mental health might be evolving in time,
getting better or getting worse.
And so then, there's this question about how that data could get
into the point of care through a system like FHIR,
which would essentially mean a need to understand what those specific sensing modalities,
how they're characterized, and then how they would fit into other more,
let's say, electronic health records types of information.
Yeah.
So I think part of the challenge there is to think about
the granularity of the data and the levels at
which you might want to access the data and expose the data.
So you think about a very fine-grain level
which might literally mean specific bouts of eye contact in
the context in which they were produced which might be useful for someone really trying
to understand in great detail a child's behavior in a particular setting.
You could also think about a summary score,
a measure of social interaction skill
that could be derived from a variety of measures not just eye contact,
and that could then become more of
a summary statistic that might be reported in a different way.
So, I think having a sense of what are the levels of granularity of the data and then
defining APIs that allow people to access those different levels in appropriate ways,
that would be the way to move forward.
But I think, we're still quite far at this point from understanding exactly how
these sensors will fit into care in specific cases like autism or mental health.
And then it's another step I think to get that into something like FHIR.
Sure, sure. So I think,
if you think about measurements of behavior and
how they might play out from the patient's point of view,
then there's at least two dimensions you can consider.
So one is a kind of opportunity for reflection.
So you have a summary of your behavior.
Let's say there's a behavioral goal that you have.
Maybe you're trying to quit smoking, for example.
So then you might have a case where there's
behavioral measures being obtained not just with glasses and cameras,
but with wearable sensors as well.
And you might imagine distilling from those measures.
Summary is a little interesting,
and piece of information that an individual might not be aware of that
might help them better understand how their behaviors affect their health outcomes.
So that could be reflected to the individual in a course granularity.
The other thing you might think about are actually mobile interventions.
So the ability to take a data item that you've obtained in the field during
someone's daily life and then use that to
assess their risk for some undesirable health outcome.
And in that case, you could think about
immediately acting on that information and thinking about
how you might intervene or provide that person with some supports in real time,
in the field that might then help them maintain
their health-related behaviors or prevent unwanted behaviors.
So both of those reflection and intervention could be supported.
Right.
So, behavioral imaging really started out with a kind of analogy to medical imaging.
So we would look at behaviors.
Particularly, we're looking initially at children with autism and
very complex behaviors around a childhood development disorders.
And we made the analogy that we want to move from a qualitative characterization of
children's behavior that currently is the state of
the art to a data-driven, very quantitative assessment,
and we made the analogy to medical imaging that succeeded in
taking qualitative states of disease and risk,
and really quantifying more precisely the patterns
of disease progression and the factors that influence them.
And so, that led us to this notion of
behavior as a construct
that you could image and you can model, and you can understand it.
And then in parallel with that,
there's been this community of folks in
mHealth which have been focused on the mobile environment,
how to get out into the real world and understand what's happening in real life.
And so, I see these as two threads that are converging,
and I think this notion of imaging is valuable as
a perspective as well as this notion of mobile health.
So we see, behavioral imaging is sitting inside
this larger umbrella of mobile health which embraces many different aspects of
mobile health-related behavior and really focusing on
the behavioral components specifically.
Absolutely, and I think
the challenge there is really to understand how context should be quantified,
and how it can be reported back.
You obviously can't. The physician doesn't
want to relive a person's life, their patients lives.
You have to give them some distilled,
essential pieces of information.
And that's really the challenge we face, I think,
is to take all the data that's available in the contextual space
and distill it down to a small set of things that are really informative and valuable.
And that, I think, is the research enterprise
we have ahead of us for the next several years.
So there is a number
of activities that are happening right now that are building toward the near future.
One effort is around building infrastructure.
So we're currently working with some collaborators at other universities in Hershey,
Memphis and other places through some NIH grants.
We're trying to build out a kind of infrastructure
for collecting a variety of different signals and
organizing them and extracting information from them and then
showing the ability to intervene in the field.
So I think we'll have some evidence over
the next couple of years of the ability to support
real-time sensor-triggered interventions that might be
the basis for a real change in health outcomes for certain conditions.
Looking ahead, I think what you really want to look to is progress on two fronts.
One is increasing standardization and
understanding around which signals are really valuable,
what is in fact the most effective way to collect them and
analyze them and get information from them,
and really moving toward standards for some of
these mobile health signals that will ultimately be of value.
And the second direction I think is really the integration of
these modalities with other capabilities for understanding health-related factors.
So integration of genomics data, for example.
So patient of genomic risk that sets them up for certain outcomes.
We're now having increasing the ability to do sequencing and understand
those states of risk well in advance of any diagnosis.
So that's a piece of information that we are currently not really
integrating with mobile health data but I think it's really important to go that route.
And then another thing you might think about is understanding a person's environment.
So drawing from other what they sometimes call digital traces,
other examples that give a context,
whether it's your social media or whether it's other aspects of your SES and so forth,
that could play a role in providing context for health outcomes.
So I think the next step is really to pull these different disparate sources of
information together and then make progress on the sensing front.
We also, by the way,
need battery life to increase and we need the sensors to get smaller.
So the things that are happening now need to continue to happen to pull
all these things together.
My pleasure.